the following program is rated G a G it
contains giggling abominable language
and grotesque sexual imagery it may
literally cause you to gag we highly
recommend you don't watch it just walk
away and just go read a book or
something or spend time with your kids
do anything but watch this guy grill
better be working on that Deen you
better be working on the [ __ ] blooper
reel Deen
[Music]
Parks and Rec let's roll I have one suit
my brown Sears three-piece Elise Yorkton
Elaine's police narc ins come over to my
house at 3:00 so you can help me prepare
make sure the mark is coming off someone
to work to do here my very best friend
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
hello hey mom you're on camera right now
say hello hello next caller
oh you work with animals right yes I do
I work a lot with animals I love it well
what is it about cats that make them
think they are so much goddamn better
than we are
I'll take my answer I'll see ya don't
Blake you can't deal with the
consequences this [ __ ] is on little man
oh sorry guys
all right lost this little pom-pom that
was on my golf glove should be on the
floor somewhere can you help me look for
it real quick here
[Applause]
hey sweetheart again just like that
three more times and then he passed away
[Laughter]
we just helped me it's really thank you
what I was saying is that awesome girls
like you who are you know not
classically hot they can go and they can
be rewarded for Leslie I have been
happily married for 28 years I met my
wife Gayle many times so um
Oh finally
and and Mark will be well this take is
so bad so so I
[Music]
Leslie doesn't like to hear her mommy
talk about sex why don't you tell us
about your escapades you little minx I
like your padfolio I'd like to talk
about government brand toothpowder and
it doesn't get your teeth clean and it
tastes and it doesn't get your teeth
clean and it tastes like would you
gentlemen like a tour not at all there
is quite literally nothing in the world
that I would rather do then take a tour
of the Parks and Rec Department hey
guess what what's that I'm awesome
okay lucky to have me here cuz I'm
farting I miss money I'm awesome okay
and you're lucky to have me here cuz I'm
frightened on some money and I'm a prize
okay and you're lucky to have me here
cuz I'm far it numbs money [ __ ] god
dammit [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm so sorry I'm
kicking your ass and pizza fight would
not do that really I really wish I would
do it
try it with a different suit I thought
you'd like this one J I thought you'd
like this one I do D Justin and I have a
similar fashion sense dangers in your
face but tasteful you like this new
button-down purple sweater best combo
sorry Brooke Brothers bought it off the
doll a vanilla chai latte for my young
nubian princess
step one we buy into this club
step two we roll over to the club either
in your mercedes-benz which is gorgeous
or my pre-owned Acura Legend which is
all right step 3 I dagger you on the
dance floor just bounce bounce bounce
bounce bounce bounce bounce bounce
step 3 I dagger you on that dance floor
I dress you with my eyes until it last
it's just me and you naked on the dance
floor you got throw up you're gonna
smile Dean I'm gonna give you 50 takes
of this one line take one and I'll do my
mic sure we'd entirely understand youth
culture I'm a much happier person now
though is the thing and I just want I
just screwed up the whole take that's
what it did did you yeah you know we go
back yeah I once french-kissed a police
dog on a dare it was weird after but
then it was okay
dog died later oh my god
aids sorry why are we going to your
mother's but wait a meeting my mother's
so uh maybe we should just write um
things down go from there
will you do it cuz I don't know how to
write print or
[Laughter]
I don't mean this in any bad way but if
you ever made out with another woman why
because for my analysis I think you love
it
you